[Music]
there's a YouTube video that's been
going around it's really gone viral
getting a lot of attention in the video
a very foul-mouthed woman appears to be
stealing rhubarb from a neighbor's
garden everybody's watching this thing
because this woman's outrageous here's a
clip well as I said before I'm very
surprised people are just hearing about
this woman now she's been a menace here
on the Warner Brothers lot for years if
you ask me that wait a minute I'm
missing a joke here there's a joke
that's missing from my who took my cue
cards
[Applause]
my cue cards are missing each other for
you to make you cards in batches
those are not your cue cards
see you damn a mommy's what are you
Nathan Fillion you say your name on
these damn cute car is my show my name
is all over the studio
those are my jokes you call these jokes
Chris Christie's fat yeah big deal Bill
Clinton's horny oh here's a joke
Larry King dinosaur they're my endcard
oh yeah I'm sorry you gotta stop
stealing my cue cards
I'm stealing [ __ ] I'm just taking out
the damn garbage I'm outta here you kiss
my ass
[Applause]
hey my team guard
you get back here those are not your
property
ah they're mine now [ __ ] they belong
everybody out here - okay have a joke
all right well anyway we got a terrific
show tonight from from casino Basic
Instinct in the new film Lovelace
award-winning actress Sharon Stone is
here seriously sliver was my favorite
time for God's sake
from the Comedy Central series the
Jeselnik offensive comedian Anthony
Jeselnik terror you gotta watch that
he's got a filthy mouth committee and
Julian McCullough is here
never heard of them bacon Franklin